you don't believe in the boogeyman you  should the saga of Michael Myers and  Laurie Strode isn't over on October 16  2020 and on October 15th 2012 on happy  Halloween Michael Halloween ends now it  looked like Michael Myers was dead for  good but we always know somehow he is  always reincarnated is this it was that  the end or with or is there a chance he  could come back do you want him to come  back of course I do  do you course you want him do you want  them to but Laurie and Michael mm-hmm  it will be the sort of love story of my  life well I mean besides my own actual  love story  it's better than the Lori Michaels story  but I love that you don't believe in the  boogeyman you should the saga of Michael  Myers and Laurie Strode isn't over on  October 16 2020 we killed and on October  15th 2009 happy Halloween Michael  Halloween ends  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]